special bulletin from the press radio news
Trenton New Jersey Bruno Richard Hauptmann
was electrocuted at 8:47 tonight for the murder
of a Lindbergh baby news comedy music the Golden
Age of Radio this is an old from the days of
bows down if it's Auto the trained seal throw
him a fish and tell him I'm busy oh wait a
minute Fred if you'll just take your nose
that one you used to talk through out of that
microphone you'll see that it's me Oh Jack Jack
Benny well I'm sure wait a minute there's a
reception goes in therefore doesn't happen
here another concert with the NBC Symphony officer
under it celebrated conductor Arturo Toscanini
I must have faith you must not be stampeded
by Roma's or get it let us unite in banishing
fear we have provided the machinery
to restore our financial system and
it is up to you to support and make it
work it is your problem my friends no
mine together we cannot fail the early
broadcasters the medium grew astounding
my friends we have survived all of the arduous
but it allowed a president in the depths of the
great depression to reassure millions as if he
were sitting right next week you have in the
darkest moments of our National Trails retained
our faith in our own ability to master our own
destiny believe me ladies and gentlemen from
the Meridian room in the Park Plaza Hotel in
New York City we bring you the music of Ramon
raquello and his orchestra radio strength was
its believability anything going out to an
entire nation of listeners had to be true
ladies and gentlemen we interrupt our program
of dance music to bring you a special bulletin
from the Intercontinental radio news at 20
minutes before 8:00 Central Time professor
Farrell of the mount Jennings Observatory Chicago
Illinois reports observing several explosions